Oh my Funky il golf Oddio l'ho preso a
uscire Hahaha Bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
Favij e oggi siamo su sonos the forest
come tutti gli altri giorni della
settimana Ormai sto parlando solo questo
perché voglio finirlo ma è veramente
figo e godetevi il gameplay Let's go
e [__] va tutta sta scritta per
quattro episodi in basso a sinistra per
questa merda di sedia almeno che bello
che bei piedi che c'hai bello accurata
questa casa qua Eh perché puoi vedere
attraverso gli spiragli che cosa succede
fuori perché gli altri si facciano i
cazzi tuoi il tutto sto casino mi viene
giustamente da chiedermi Ma dove minchia
si è cacciata Eccolo che è il video
stavo dicendo
Ma che sei stronzo Tra il Kelvin che se
ne va perché a lui non gliene frega
niente Tanto ci sono io che difendo Eh
ce la serva qua che pulisce che cazzo fa
Oh ma questo pazzo Allora raga
facciamoci tutti quanti Un tripudio di
cazzi nostri va bene Tanto sto sprecando
Tutti i dardi bravo
Cioè guarda che sono i 2000 Ma ragazzi
ma che che ce l'avete controlli ma cosa
vi ho fatto Ma perché ultimamente Oh
ma cos'è che vuole sta gente cosa volete
caca palle
Ma qual è il tuo problema Guarda che mi
fai randellare la casa pure a me
ma mi spiegate Qual è il vostro problema
cosa vuole attenzione Oh my God
oh oh oh Dio l'ho preso uscire ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah
frate sei stato protagonista della cosa
più bella che se mi sia mai successa nel
nei miei video probabilmente bellissimo
ragazzi Questo è stato incredibile
scusatetevi
e ti sei perso la cosa più bella del
video e dopo questo io posso concludere
qua mi sa eh a parte sta cagata raga
andiamo a vedere appunto Allora
ricapitolando io ho trovato eh 62.000
tessere che sono qua L'ultima è la
chiave magnetica eh per visitatori che
non che tra l'altro Scusatemi come fa
quella per visitatori ad avere più
potere di quella vip e di quella per lo
staff Cioè è assurda sta roba Però vabbè
andiamo Kelvin ti Se ti va di Se ti va
di giocare anche tu a Sons of the forest
non so se ti va e noi vorrei romperti le
palle se ti va di fare qualcosa vieni ma
solo se hai voglia eh Non è che devi sta
qua a pettinare le bambole va Ah vedo ci
sono dei bunker dall'altra parte allora
ragazzi la parte sinistra l'abbiamo
fatta tutta Ci sono ancora i punti viola
non perché in questo gioco i punti Viola
dopo che prendi i GPS e continuano a
spawnare Boh non la capirò mai sta roba
però della parte destra non ho ancora
visto praticamente quasi nulla quindi
andiamo di là
uh la colazione
perfetto
Eccoci qua vieni servity Kelvin
non è per vegani qui però nella foresta
devi fare qualcosa che poi degna capito
si mangia
rou carne collected Row carne mangiatela
pure Eccoci qua Mi dispiace ragazzi
Anche a me i Bambi li lascerei vivi però
devi devi bagnare che devi fare devi
bagnare avete notato raga che non si è
più fatta vedere Virginia faston che è
comunque in giro ancora nella foresta
che non so dove ma non sei più mostrata
Ah qua c'è lo Strunz allora Aspetta che
torno un attimo che sono armato fratello
Pam Tutto bene No perché mi ricordo che
noi avevamo un contenzioso
Vediamo Ah minchia l'ho preso proprio
Inter collo mi Scusami frate non volevo
È solo che mi sta un po' sul cazzo
stacca in pelle con lechted Mmm sei
contento Kelvin di forniamoci ne
mettiamo Oh bello eh fratello occhio
occhio
ma scappa Kevin Ma che cazzo fai è scemo
ma fratello di correre corri Oh merda
questo non gliene frega un cazzo gigante
Lo so
Minchia se non muori adesso Ciao Minchia
gli ho ficcato una freccia nell'occhio
proprio guarda che mira guarda guarda
nel naso c'è un altro stronzo Kevin
ti scuoia la famiglia Vabbè che tu sei
Madonna ragazzi ma eh
gli manca pure il Birillo questo qua
Vabbè sulla t'ho preso sulla spalla
quanto Drama Madonna Calvin ha te lo
devo curare ti ho curato dottoressa
Kelvin tutto a posto Stai bene È un
Bijou sei grazie Ah bello Beh abbiamo il
pallone da calcio Vai Kevin vado in
porta io Fammi i mondiali Lito giochiamo
al dialito non so se non sai come si
gioca mondiali Vabbè e basta dirlo
scherzavo Riprendiamo il nostro Quante
frecce ho giusto per chiedere invece di
fare del pirla
7 attenzione che qua rischiamo di
sprecarle tutte Beh ragazzi allora il
bunker è relativamente vicino tra una
canzone e l'altra ho fatto fuori in
accampamenti intero ma non c'era niente
alla fine ho guadagnato solo due teli
porca tua madre morta Ma chi è si vola
my boys si dovrebbe essere arrivati
teoricamente Vediamo se lo slittino mi
porta nel punto giusto Minchia che
randellate all'albero e ci siamo my boys
siamo arrivati al punto teoricamente
questo qua Eccolo ok Perché mi dice che
c'è un bunker Ma questo è un
accampamento un'altra accampamento regà
Oh merda c'è anche un sacco di gente
Scusatemi raga e devo devo scavare mi
serve devo scavare scusate
Ok son due Vabbè nel mentre vi secco
tutti quanti ragazzi devo scavare per
terra poi me ne vado giuro Tolgo il
disturbo Guarda tranquillo
scavo e poi vado poi devi farti i cazzi
vostri Eh oh a te ma Kelvin Ma che cazzo
fai devi corre corri estinto di
sopravvivenza Kelvin sai che cazzo è
faccio io qua oh porca [__] Kelvin
Kelvin occhio Minchia che calcio m'ha
dato che cazzo è questa è Sparta
ha arrestato pure il compagno hanno lo
stava prendendo per trascinarlo va bene
Beh non è stata la miglior scelta
fratello se posso essere sincero però ok
Porca [__]
Ma che cazzo fate Eh che cazzo Sei Majin
Bu Ma questa è scema vabbè raga abbiamo
sterminato un altro accampamento
scaviamo Questo era quello dove mi aveva
legato al palo era questo qua ragazzi
non quell'altro me lo ricordo bene cioè
sto trono Il trono di spam Ah posso
anche sedermi sto bene Kevin
no eh Vabbè L'importante è essere
sinceri nella vita che Elmi Bravo grazie
Allora Pala ed è il momento eh Fammi la
guardia che se arriva qualcuno so cazzi
[Musica]
Oh vamos inside my boys Questa è
maintency
qua sento che ci sono amici tuoi giocate
non fate casino e io arrivo eh
che questi lo so io che fanno casino oh
ah Allora qua ci sono mai entrato
ragazzi BPER Electric è molto simile a
quella ragazzi Qua non sono mai entrato
veramente non so cosa ci sia
Attenzione ragazzi Ecco qua si fa brutta
se per caso c'è una scossina elettrica
sono defunto Buongiorno
Che è allagata va bene
Ah wow quindi è molto simile all'altro
che avevo trovato e qua c'è la stanza
dove si dorme però è tutta allagato
Porca [__]
questa Me la magno c'è un'altra tessera
per caso
no però ho trovato
silenziatore con lei cioè silenziatore
Ragazzi ma veramente a parte che ho
anche il mirino laser che non ci ho
fatto mai niente Cioè si può combinare
Vai Minchia è diventato Metal Gear sto
gioco ragazzi cazzo e poi il mirino
laser Perché cos'è per esempio la
pistola cioè la pistola ragazzi è
diventata ma neanche Call of Duty una
pistola Guarda che roba Ma che cazzo è
sta pistola Scusate ma dai ma che è
Special forces proprio questa qua Ah per
dormire Vabbè
Oh se la taccia in discoteca Cos'è
questo trappola per orsi Arco composto
Ecco Arco composto mi mancava ragazzi no
mi sono bagnate le medicine che è
stupido non vedo una sega eh Però
vediamo
Ho anche mille frecce dell'Arco oltre
che averle per la balestra quindi mi ha
dato anche bene finito raga eh non è
questo il bunker per andare avanti però
silenziatore Arco vi devo dire Non è
male Madonna la pistola così ragazzi è
che è è mio padre Cioè veramente
incredibile va bene e Kevin ha i figli
di giocare che adesso Arrivo eh Mi sento
che fate casino qua ve lo buco sto
pallone eh
a posto eh non c'è nessuno va bene
andiamo via Allora qua abbiamo fatto
Vediamo se riusciamo a capire dove
andare questo è un book è bello è questo
di là andiamo dall'altra parte della
montagna Let's go Forse con lo slittino
ci arrivo prima credo eh A meno che non
mi ammazzi potrebbe succedere anche
questo Eh ragazzi Non vi prometto niente
ma io ci provo io lo Let's go ah ah
ok Oh minchia qua mi faccio una discesa
ragazzi specie ci provo Minchia Oddio il
2000 all'ora normalmente sarei morto sei
volte però vabbè ma guarda quanto scende
è pazzo è pazzo incagliato in un albero
fa niente Kelvin che mi segue a piedi
cazzo sei Usain Bolt Ok
ora Madonna che casino
sono pazzo che Gardaland
fatto un volo raga'
eh pure Vabbè e non ho capito dove sta
andando però mi diverto quindi facciamo
forse forse forse forse è un po' troppo
eh ragazze andiamo dall'altra parte
Kelvin è rimasto Beh ma neanche così
indietro Eh ragazzi il prossimo bunker
lontanissimo tra l'altro è laggiù e sono
un uomo mi sento uomo quindi voglio
scendere
ok
Oh santo di Dio eh
ma è pazzo è pazzo è pazzo e pazzo
è la madonna Oh salve Ma che posto
Incredibile è
[Musica]
i cocktail non hai una bella cera
Comunque fratello Vabbè non importa
Siamo quasi arrivati al bunker bella
'sta parte dell'isola Comunque bella
allegra ragazzi credo che dipenda dalle
punto di spawn cioè Uno potrebbe
spawnare anche qua con l'elicottero
quando cadi all'inizio non è che io sono
caduto in mezzo alla montagna però c'è
gente che magari casca qua piuttosto che
dove sono cascato io quindi dipende un
po' dalle zone dove ti trovi va un po' a
culo Vabbè Porca [__] Ah Salve Vieni
vieni gente qua Vabbè Meno male che non
so spawnato di qua perché è un po' una
zona di merda Allora palla già pronta
perché ci siamo ragazzi eh ma tanto Son
le è anche ora di andare a dormire quasi
quindi sbrighiamoci perché qua diventi
buio
eh Eccoci
Let's go Ah ma non è non c'è la pala qua
Ok allora non c'è bisogno di scavare
forse Ragazzi questa parte io non l'ho
mai vista eh Allora ragazzi vi sto
adesso si fa sul serio eh pistola basta
cazzi si fa così allora bello Questa è
una cover è un bunker molto uh
cos'è
è sfondatissimo questo qua
Madonna raga che è ma questo non l'ho
mai visto giorno ulula c'è di sotto di
sopra
tessera ok Vediamo di sopra cosa c'è
e di sopra
una porta Ah non c'è niente dietro c'è
un muro è una porta che Ah perché è
crollato è crollato tutto va bene Allora
c'è un bunker con tutto crollato tranne
la parte di qua che però è aperta Cioè
nel senso della prima con la tessera
giorno
Salve minchia quanto va in profondità
questo Ragazzi incredibile ma Kevin è
rimasto di sopra in tutto questo ma
posso mettermi dell'armatura raga in
tutto ciò Scusatemi
Allora my boys Eh qua Madonna è casino
però sento rumorini Eh certo rumorino
cos'è
altolà con la pistola si passa la roba
Ciao ciao
che cazzo è successo
cosa
che che cazzo è successo ragazzi Quindi
ragazzi anche il video di oggi è finito
il prossimo Gameplay sarà quello finale
è un mi piace e noi ci rivediamo molto
presto col prossimo episodio di the
forest Sons of the forest mi dimentico
sempre lasciate un bel commentino e noi
ci vediamo al prossimo episodio bella
ragazzi